so I thought this was really fascinating
doctors have been working on a test to
find out if elderly patients will die
within 30 days and the reason they're
doing this is so that they can decide
what kind of treatment people want do
they want to just send people home so
that they can be with their loved ones
do they want to try experimental
medicines things of that nature so we've
got a little more info for you the
checklist will prevent futile and
expensive medical treatments which
merely prolonged suffering the test
looks at 29 indicators of health
including age illness mental impairment
previous emergency admissions and heart
rate and produces a percentage chance of
death within 1 month and 12 weeks it
will provide a starting point for honest
talk with patients and families about
recognizing that dying is part of the
life cycle but I think this is
fascinating at many levels I don't think
we talk about death enough it's one of
the two things what's the other one
taxes there you go that we all have to
do in life and it is part of the circle
of life so this actually seems pretty
interesting to me in my own personal
life with two of my grandmother's they
both sort of had beautiful endings where
we had a week with them and everyone was
able to be there one of my grandma's
went into hospice and we were all able
to say goodbye and all that kind of
stuff but there are so many examples
where we keep people on machines for an
extremely long amount of time and by the
way this study is not about young people
that maybe are in a coma or in a
vegetative this is about old people that
are not going to come out the other side
so this is this is kind of this is sort
of what science is all about yeah yeah I
think I think it's actually great I mean
a few people know this but medical care
is the third leading cause of death in
the United States there are literally
12,000 people a year that died due to
unnecessary surgeries and so at the end
of a person's life we're able to say
okay look enough is enough we're not
gonna like try anything too crazy you
know we're gonna let this person like
live out the rest of their natural life
and I think that's a good thing yeah I
just worry that we would never see this
happen in the United States this is a
British initiative and yeah or a UK
initiative and the truth of the matter
is we have this weird this weird kind of
concept in America of like push push
push push push until the end the idea
that people that is
did suicide is completely against the
law except we're like in Oregon I think
is one of the only states yeah maybe
there's a couple of others now where and
not even assisted suicide but what's the
word I'm looking for
that's kind of the bill that is a step
in the right direction I think that this
is like a no-brainer step in the right
direction but I bet you if we tried to
pass a law like that people would really
push back yeah so why is it that the
religious people the ones that believe
in heaven right the ones that believe in
the afterlife are also the people that
want to keep everybody on machines
they're there you know I mean they want
you to go to the netherworld and then at
the same time they want to keep you here
via science it's like again this goes
we've had a real theme with this episode
but there's this strange disconnect
between we all have in these really
emotional situations but the truth is I
think in practice more individuals would
actually you know if it was your mother
if it was your brother or sister you
would want to make the decision that
that ease their suffering but I think
that when we step away from it and we
think about it in global terms there's
this intense fear I think and I don't
know if it's coming specifically from
the right or specifically from the
religious right I should say but there's
this intense fear that like I don't want
a doctor making a decision about when I
live or die and what if the doctor does
that and I get that like this checklist
for example it's not well tested I would
like to see a year of this being
implemented
but not actually like where somebody
comes in you do the checklist and then
you wait and you see how long it
actually takes and and say all right so
there's exactly because I kind of
understand that minor fear that crops up
in somebody's mind where they go oh well
my grandma came in and she could have
lived five more years but they did that
doctor decided that she didn't deserve
any more treatment and who is he to do
that so I get that concern but at the
same time this idea of dying with
dignity yeah I think it's such an
important thing we need to be exploring
I want that yeah back to your point I
feel like they're just hedging their
bets like just in case of their right
yeah but I think we would all be that
way I think all of us would say I don't
know you know I'm ready for it when it
happens we'll and then right before like
have you ever watched somebody die
yeah it's a really intense experience
and it's not uncommon for in those final
throws people to go like I'm really
scared like of course you're scared
that's what everybody's thinking about
their whole lives it's something to be
afraid of and so at the very end you
might know I changed my mind this isn't
what I want unfortunately that's where
life takes you yeah do you think part of
the thing that will muck this whole
thing up yeah we need to obviously find
out a little more the evidence of how
this will all work is the fear of the
legal stuff which i think is partly what
you were alluding to there that people
are gonna sign something and say okay
I'm gonna let them go home and then
after 30 days someone's gonna still be
alive and then they're gonna go alright
now we're gonna be in a lawsuit like
this is just where I think partly that's
why we don't have the proper discussion
about death and circle of life because
then lawyers get involved and everybody
fights about everything the bureaucracy
of death the business of death yeah it's
crazy but I think that I think that
initiatives like this will go a long way
towards at the very least igniting
conversation